Now, the answer is rather obvious because I've already told you that we don't know if P=NP
and actually, we believe that it isn't the case.
The interesting part about this one here is why is the answer no,
and the answer is that v might actually be exponential in n.
So when we build this table here and you remember it has n rows and it has v columns,
v could be some exponential function of n, so v could for example be 2^n
because we haven't specified the maximum value of those objects here.
And that is why this algorithm is a pseudopolynomial algorithm because it looks
very polynomial, but actually there are cases where it is not polynomial.
But you can already see why I said at the beginning that knapsack seems to be one of the
rather simple NP complete problems--simply because the existence
of the pseudopolynomial algorithm here.